"Guys"
Alright, Niko is outside right now with the Node Crew,
we're gonna go kick the soccerball at them.
Blowing up the beach ball, that already makes me light headed:
So giant soccerball. I almost passed out
Mmm
I can't open the door any further.
"Ouuughgghg"
We needed Spencer super-strength
Just like when a man conquers Mt. Everest, we ask him "Why?".
I think that's why we got that soccer ball out that day.
Ohhhhhhhhhhhhh
Brandons like:
"Is this the giant soccer ball?"
and the door came up you can see it like rolling down the stairs.
and just like this huuuge ball
Gotta keep my Pokemon kicking in there,
while we're playing.
make sure we get all these steps, don't wanna waste 'em
Node v Corridor
First of all
Those guys
Making all those videos over there
Talking about us
Taking Sam and Niko from us
I've had it.
But other than that generally it was, I thought it  was very important that the guys just stay fit, ya know?
They've gone.
THEY WERE GONE!
*Weak battlecry*
When I first kicked that ball, I was not expecting it to feel like I was kicking an elephant
Playing normal soccer, it hurts my body.
Don't exercise enough.
GIANT soccer hurts way more.
Yeah, if they act like a team
and like pass to eachother,
but they're literally just headbutting back and forth.
It's like: No, like propel it down the field.
Like us girls trying to showcase.
Yeah, its just like "Who's stronger?", it's like come on.
"Who is smarter?" Is the question.
Come on guys, we're team players. That's why they date us.
*Grunt*
So Pokemon GO came out like 4 days ago, on friday.
Sam was in Iceland.
When it came out
Now he's back.
Sam came back to all of us being like level 10's, 11's and we're like
"Sam, you've gotta get this game ASAP"
And he's like:
"You guys are crazy"
And then he played the game and he's like "Yup, nope just kidding, we're all crazy, crazy about Pokemon"
And uh...
I'm already crazy about Pokemon
I mean, we just ran a friggin 3 month long D&D Pokemon game.
Yeah.
Soo...
We're coming up with idea about a Pokemon GO video
Like I don't want to be this into a game that everyone else is into
Just like the hipster inside of me
Dude, I've played so much.
*Laughter*
*Strong Battlecry*
Carmicheal, he uhhh....
You know....
was getting into the game
He got a little bit too into it.
I'm glad he was alright ya know, that was a nice suprise.
*Celebratory screams*
*Jake gets overzealous*
I may have gotten a little bit overzealous when the goal happened.
*Jake still overzealous*
*Carmichael joins in*
I think the fact that Carmicheal jumped in with me during that time really made it.
Carmichael has to go to a dinner and now he's all covered in schmut.
So that's great.
It's so big you can't see if somebody's on the other side of it.
You go to kick it but there is this hesitation that at any second it could just like explode into your face cause somebody else might kick it right there.
One, one.
Come on you guys!
Come on!
Next one wins.
Alright.
Woop woop
I was hoping that it was caught on camera so it would make a good highlight
Next time, first person to get a goal wins!
Because other than that, I would have  no
No justification for taking a hit like that.
*Weakly* I want...
I want to *mumble*
If they took the goal posts and they opened  them up so that it was just like if you get past the line, someone would score a point.
The goal is now: The entire line.
Scary voice: Trench Warfare!
Come on!
You know, I'm glad I got wrecked once.
There we go!
Lost with the height advantage!
Node wins.
Well I guess we need to work on our soccer skills.
God damn I missed everything
Turns out it's really, really exhausting.
I was not expecting the game to be that exhausting.
Phhh
I think it was all the jumping.
Oh, so exhausting.
*Heavy breathing* My lungs...
I...
I will avenge this!!!
*Weakly* I will avenge this....
Bloody mess, man...
War, war never changes...
Huuhh
I guess that shows you how much we want to play Giant Soccer again.
It's kinda sad.
But not as sad as not subscribing to Samandniko
That's right.
We put our necks on the line playing Giant Soccer for you, for your enjoyment.
I think the least you can do is subscribe.
I'll wait.
The rest of you guys who are subscribed you are cool, you can go
But I want you, you unsubscriber right there watching this right now.
Click that subscribe button...
Aaaah :D
Yeeahh >:)
Ah, if we play Giant Soccer against Rocketjump, we would just slaughter them.